i mentioned in the last segment the name
kevin mccarthy there is an unbelievable
situation going on with kevin mccarthy
kevin mccarthy is the house minority
leader he's a republican he republicans
are in the minority for now in the house
and kevin mccarthy is their leader
now
it wouldn't be shocking because of what
we know
that people like liz cheney in the
aftermath of the january 6 riots were
talking about can we invoke the 25th
amendment to remove donald trump should
we demand that donald trump resign
that's liz cheney we know she doesn't
like trump
but kevin mccarthy is a guy who is the
uber trump loyalist
and reports started coming out last week
from the new york times that republican
house minority leader kevin mccarthy was
going around in the aftermath of the
trump riots saying trump should resign
trump should resign
in response to that report by the new
york times mccarthy denied the entire
thing and this is this is such a
brilliant series of events so new york
times reports that mccarthy denies it he
put it puts out a statement saying the
new york times reporting on me is
totally false and wrong
it comes as no surprise that the
corporate media is obsessed with doing
everything it can to further a liberal
agenda this promotional book tour is no
different if the reporters were
interested in truth why would they ask
for comment after the book was printed
the past year and a half have proven
that our country was better off when
trump was in the white house and rather
than address the real issues facing
americans the corporate media is more
concerned with profiting from
manufactured political intrigue from
politically motivated sources so he
denies that he ever said we gotta we
gotta look at trump resigning
and then
rachel maddow got the video
the audio i guess i should better say
after kevin mccarthy said oh no i never
said anything about trump should resign
audio of liz cheney speaking to kevin
mccarthy given to rachel maddow on msnbc
proves it is all true listen to this
conversation i'm here thanks kevin um
i guess there's a question when when we
were talking about the 25th amendment
resolution um
and you asked if you know what happens
if it gets there after he's gone is is
there any chance are you hearing that he
might
resign is there any reason to think that
might
happen
i've had some few discussions
my gut tells me no
um
i'm seriously
thinking about having that conversation
with him tonight okay that's kevin
mccarthy saying i'm thinking about
talking to trump about resigning tonight
he denied that this ever happened
here it is on tape i talked to him in a
couple days
from what i know of him i mean you guys
all know him too do you think he'd ever
back away but
what what i think i'm going to do is i'm
going to call him
my
this is what i think um
no one will pass the house
i think there's a chance you'll pass the
senate even when he's gone
um
and
i think there's a lot of different
ramifications for that now
i haven't had a discussion
with them that if they did design with
it not happen so what i'm understanding
this is is
initially they were talking about the
25th amendment but that's something the
cabinet does my understanding is now
mccarthy is saying
if he were to resign would democrats
agree not to impeach that's my
understanding of this part
now this is one personal fear i have
um
i do not want to get into any
conversation about
partying again i mean the only
discussion i would have with him
is that i think this will pass and it
will be my recommendation we should be
gone
it would be my recommendation
that he should resign so just caught
caught mccarthy was lying he said i
never talked to trump about that uh but
i'm sorry he said i never said i was
going to talk to trump about that i
never said he should resign and there he
is on the recording saying i think he
should resign the reporters have even
more check out this piece of an
interview from the rachel maddow show so
just just to underscore this just to be
clear mr mccarthy and his office have
denied that he said he was going to call
trump and tell him to resign you have it
on tape we just heard that he in fact
said that his also he is also today
denied that he called for members of his
own caucus other house republicans to
have their social media access cut off
you've also got that on tape
that's correct and we have a lot more on
tape from this period which is at the
highest levels of american politics it
is it is sensitive it's delicate uh and
it's high stakes and we have it all
on tape and
it's going to i think tell a very
different story about this period than
the story that many people are trying to
tell right now there's another recording
that they have where mccarthy says i've
had it with this guy speaking about
trump
all right i know i know this is not uh
fun i know this is not great i know this
is
very tough but what i want to do
especially through here
is i don't want to rush things i want
everybody to have all the information
needed
um
i i've had it with this guy
what he did is unacceptable
um nobody can defend that and nobody
should defend it
okay so that's pretty remarkable stuff
now eventually after all of the claims
that uh kevin mccarthy made about the
new york times article were refuted by
audio reporters finally got to mccarthy
and they said okay so like
they got you right and mccarthy shifts
the goal posts and he does it pretty
smoothly see if you can pick it up
congressman uh have you spoken with
president trump recently did you speak
with him last night i know i spoke to
him twice today i just spoke to him an
hour ago
how was your conversation uh did you
talk to him about uh the new york times
report and the conversation you had
about potentially asking him to resign
because the conversation here is what
they
what they said we did we never did i
mean i never asked president trump to
resign
we both talked about that
so this is the key point we don't even
need to watch the rest of the video
mccarthy goes i never asked trump to
resign now that may well be true
but the claim initially was mccarthy
said trump should resign and mccarthy
denied it and he's on audio saying trump
should resign mccarthy wants to say
something different which is i never
asked trump to resign that's not what he
originally uh denied now does this make
republicans look better or worse
one perspective is this makes
republicans look better they're not that
crazy they saw how bad trump was and
they wanted him to resign
i say this makes them look worse because
what i understand is they saw how bad
trump was
and privately they knew that this guy
had to go and he was a danger but
publicly they insisted everything's fine
trump's great he's the greatest
president we support him they publicly
supported a guy that they knew was bad
for the country merely for their own
political benefit so i believe this
makes them look worse now last thing
it's great that this is coming out and
everything
but why
did it take a year for this stuff to
come out
as usual it's the authors holding stuff
in order to sell books and i understand
why they're doing it i understand the
financial incentive but for the country
it would have been much better if these
tapes came out in real time these
conversations some of them happened on
january 10th i'm not saying that if they
came out on january 10th
maybe the reporters didn't have them on
january 10th but if instead of a year
later or more we knew in the moment that
republicans were saying trump should
resign
it actually might have pushed him to
resign i'm not saying it would have but
it would have at least had a shot and
now it's 15 months later 16 months later
and we're learning about it now that's
not new
that's how the business works
incredible stuff about kevin mccarthy
and
what else will we find out in the next
week send me your thoughts find me on
twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which just makes it really easy for me
to get the vitamins and minerals that i
want every day i don't always have time
to get exactly what i want from the
foods i'm eating but that's why athletic
greens ag-1 is so great it's a solution
that gives you everything in one scoop
and you get 75 high-quality vitamins and
minerals as well as probiotics so it
supports gut health it is one of the
great sort of add-ons to having proper
balanced nutrition
athletic greens ag-1 has become a
regular part of my day i'll put it in a
smoothie it tastes great sometimes i'll
just drink it by itself and it's been a
really great and convenient way to get
everything i would get from a
multivitamin and minerals and probiotics
that i might otherwise take separately
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase when you go to athletic
greens.com pacman the link is down below